From superhero action thrillers to down-to-earth
dramas and everything in between, here are
all the returning TV shows that will blow
you away in 2019.
It looks like HBO’s True Detective is determined
to redeem itself after its unfortunate sophomore
slump.
Featuring an all-new, all-star cast, the show’s
third season has a solid foundation from which
it can spin out into the mind-bending antics
we’ve all come to love and expect.
The new episodes will follow state detective
Wayne Hays, his partner Roland, and schoolteacher
Amelia Reardon as they investigate the mysterious
disappearance of children in southern Missouri
during the 1980s.
Much like the show’s groundbreaking first
season, the third installment will take place
across separate time periods, telling its
story through flashback and flashforward sequences.
Judging by the teaser trailer HBO unveiled
for the new season, it seems that fans should
prepare themselves for a wild and emotional
ride when True Detective airs on January 3rd,
2019.
Just who will win the Iron Throne?
That question has perplexed fantasy fans for
over twenty years, and should finally be answered
in 2019, when HBO airs the final season of
their wildly popular fantasy drama Game of
Thrones.
These episodes, which may run up to two hours
long, based on reports, are also said to be
the show's costliest yet, with one of their
huge battle set pieces allegedly taking a
whopping 55 days to film.
“Rest assured, your grace, you can count
on the Iron Bank's support.
As soon as the gold arrives.”
Considering the show already has a huge body
count, it seems fairly safe to expect that
quite a few fan favorite characters could
end up biting the dust in the show's final
season, too.
Set your DVRs now, this isn’t going to be
a season you want to miss.
2019 is gonna be a strange year, not least
because the third season of Netflix's sci-fi
hit Stranger Things is set to hit the streaming
platform.
This time around, the story will span eight
episodes, down from the usual ten, and will
feature the Hawkins gang dealing with all-new
new "forces of evil."
The series is also set to feature another
time jump, and will be set in the summer,
a notable departure from the last two seasons.
Although details are few and far between on
just where the show will go next plot-wise,
we do know a few details, including the fact
that it’ll feature more of season two fan
favorite Erica, as well as another likely
appearance from Kali, who should help to open
up more of the mystery surrounding Eleven's
past.
“Sister.”
Claire Foy may be leaving her post as Queen
Elizabeth for season three of Netflix’s
The Crown, but someone equally decorated will
assume the throne: Golden Globe-winning star
Olivia Colman, who’ll portray Her Royal
Highness in her later years.
Season 3 will also see a slew of new cast
members take over other roles.
These include Helena Bonham Carter, who’ll
play an older version of Princess Margaret;
Tobias Menzies taking on Matt Smith's role
as Prince Philip; and Ben Daniels becoming
the new Lord Snowdon.
And that's just a hint of what’s to come
in the third season of The Crown, which will
chronicle events such as the Aberfan disaster,
Princess Margaret's five-year affair with
Roddy Llewellyn and Harold Wilson's tenure
as Prime Minister.
Fans will also become acquainted with Camilla
Parker Bowles, the second wife of Prince Charles,
as well as the late Princess Diana.
Big Little Lies was a massive hit for HBO
on its release last year, earning awards season
love across the board for its stars Reese
Witherspoon, Nicole Kidman, Shailene Woodley
and Laura Dern.
Although the show was initially billed as
a limited series, it wasn't all that surprising
when HBO ordered a second season, to be written
by season one veteran David E. Kelley.
Season two will also be drawn from a story
by Liane Moriarty, the author of the book
on which the series is based.
The main cast is all set to return, with Transparent
and American Honey director Andrea Arnold
taking the director’s chair.
If that’s not enough, Big Little Lies has
also added another huge name to its cast:
Meryl Streep, set to play the mother of Alexander
Skarsgard's character, Perry.
Joe Penhall and David Fincher's gripping,
gory, and groovy '70s crime drama is coming
back for more later next year.
Mindhunter was renewed by Netflix for a second
season right after the release of the first,
which chronicled the efforts of FBI agents
Holden Ford, Bill Tench and psychologist Wendy
Carr to establish the Behavioral Science Unit
at the FBI Academy.
Interviewing serial killers in the hopes of
understanding the motivations behind their
grisly crimes was just part of the job.
“You want truffles?
You gotta get in the dirt with the pigs.”
Fincher has previously told Billboard that
Mindhunter’s third season will center around
the notorious Atlanta child murders, which
took place between 1979 and 1981.
Real-life FBI agent John E. Douglas, on whom
the show’s Holden character is based, profiled
a man named Wayne Williams, believing him
to be one of the perpetrators.
Williams eventually went to jail, but Douglas'
actions in getting him there resulted in him
being censured by the FBI.
Given Holden’s breakdown at the end of the
first season, it wouldn’t be surprising
if he becomes a little more radical in his
methods as the second progresses.